hey 42 here have you ever looked back on
something you've said or done and
thought
whoa it was that psycho i'm not talking
about that awkward moment when you
called your boss dad
i'm referring to those occasions when
you've totally
overreacted to a situation perhaps you
lost it as another driver in rush hour
traffic
maybe you turned into a fire-breathing
maniac after stepping on your kid's lego
maybe you had a fight with your ex and
threw a toaster at her
it happens most of us can recall at
least one or two occasions in which we
behave like a character from
a stephen king novel though we're
usually too embarrassed or ashamed to
admit it
this kind of behavior is usually so
unusual and catches you're so off guard
that it seems like a different person
altogether
centuries ago periodic spells of
insanity were attributed
to the cycles of the moon hence the word
lunatic but nowadays we have
neuroscience to provide a more plausible
explanation
you sometimes act this way because your
brain
has been hijacked before you whip out
your tinfoil hat
let me explain your brain is not being
controlled by aliens or
lizard people or any outside entity for
that matter
it's an inside job and as we'll see
shortly
it involves a formidable cocktail of
chemicals
in fact almost every decision you make
is influenced by a collection of
powerful brain chemicals
that controls a variety of physical and
psychological functions
including your mood your eating patterns
your breathing
your digestion your ability to learn
and your sleep cycles there are
six principal brain chemicals that
control
you on a daily basis and dictate
your personality
adrenaline dhea dopamine
serotonin and oxytocin
let's discover how each has been
controlling your life up to now
and the simple steps you can take to
influence
those chemicals to hack your brain and
change your life let's go back for a
moment to one of those times you acted
a little wacko remember i said your
brain had been hijacked
well it probably was by a collection
of nuclei deep within the brain's
temporal lobe
called the amygdala this small
almond-shaped brain mass is tasked with
keeping us safe
usually the data received from our
senses is processed by the neocortex
responsible for thinking reasoning
planning
and storing long-term memories making up
most of the mammalian brain layer the
neocortex evolved
later birds for instance don't have a
neocortex
hence bird brain which is why they fly
into windows
and then do the same damn thing the very
next week
most of the time the neocortex is the
primary arbiter of our actions and
reasoning
but when danger is present the amygdala
a much older and more primal part of the
brain
has the power to take the reins and
activate the fight
or flight response this is the
neurological equivalent of your
pants and hitting the big red button
instantly your body is flooded with
adrenaline and cortisol
two powerful hormones designed to
prepare you for combat
or escape it's sort of like turning into
the hulk
except you're not green and you usually
keep your pants on
in phytoflight the amygdala bypasses the
neocortex and takes over decision-making
that's why in times of extreme fear you
feel like you're in a mental fog
and unable to think clearly this entire
process happens in milliseconds
the fight or flight response has two
stages firstly
the autonomic nervous system which is
piloted by the amygdala
and controls involuntary bodily
functions such as your heartbeat
triggers an almost instantaneous
reaction to the impending danger
this happens so quickly that your body
will react before you're consciously
aware
of the danger secondly the sympathetic
nervous system kicks in
which pumps your body full of adrenaline
increases blood flow to your muscles by
300 percent
widens airways in your lungs to increase
breathing
your pupils dilate your hearing becomes
sharper
and much more it's your brain's
equivalent of dumping petrol on a
bonfire
and the entire process takes a few
seconds to a few minutes to fully engage
we are not in control of this response
which is how we arrive at
the amygdala hijack and the profound
impact that cortisol and adrenaline are
having in all of our modern lives
the term amygdala hijack was coined by
daniel goldman in his book
emotional intelligence and refers to a
sudden and intense emotional reaction
that's
out of proportion to the surrounding
situation
to see it in action look out for
examples of road rage
watch a football fan react to his player
being fouled
or read twitter during national
elections
or any other time to be honest the
problem is that
we no longer spend the majority of our
days on the open savannah
and when your amygdala is hijacked you
lose control over your senses and
can't moderate your emotions in a
rational
manner like an instagram takeover of
your brain by someone with rabies
the amygdala and fight-or-flight
response are actually
a nuisance in the modern day office
environment and you end up
involuntarily punching your co-worker in
the crotch
because he snuck up behind you wielding
a hole punch
the amygdala hijack is considered a
modern malady because
it is the product of persistent stress
and the consequent
overproduction of adrenaline and
cortisol
as you'll recall these two chemicals are
released in force during the fight or
flight response
as previously mentioned this survival
mechanism used to serve as well
earlier in human history when we needed
to constantly be on the lookout for
predators or
attacks by marauding tribes the threats
were physical and real but
for most of us alive in the 21st century
death at the jaws of a wild animal
is not a major concern we are far more
likely to be worried about
our job our relationship or paying our
mortgage
today's threats are mostly psychological
yet the chemical process in our brain
remains the same
unfortunately despite the awesome power
it wields
the amygdala is not very good at
discerning the difference between
a risk to our physical well-being and a
threat
to our psychological safety when you're
in a work meeting and your boss
unexpectedly turns to you in front of 10
other people
and demands to know your opinion right
there and then your amygdala doesn't see
boss using his power to put me in an
uncomfortable position
it just sees lion and opens the
floodgates of adrenaline and cortisol
that's why sometimes when you're
abruptly put on the spot you may
suddenly
feel hot perceive your heart thumping
get sweaty palms
and find it impossible to think of a
sensible answer
it's not because you're stupid you might
be it's because you're in fight or
flight mode
the adrenaline and cortisol in your
system have cut off access to your
higher faculties it's only after this
chemical rush dissipates
that you suddenly think of a hundred
things you should have said
that transition back to normality is
supposed to be quite quick
the fight or flight response is designed
to be a short and sharp
reaction however the chronic stress of
modern life
keeps cortisol levels unnaturally
elevated
as your brain tries to keep you alert
and ready to respond to danger
your body also works overtime to deliver
repetitive bursts of adrenaline in
response to
apparent perils in the environment
over time the results of this imbalance
can be catastrophic
left untreated high cortisol can lead to
elevated blood sugar
weight gain especially belly fat a
suppressed immune system
and increased risk of serious health
conditions like cardiovascular disease
osteoporosis insulin resistance and
diabetes
if adrenaline levels stay elevated too
long they can leave you feeling
overly excited ungrounded and fidgety
making you seem manic research has shown
that you may be able to lower your
cortisol levels
by engaging in stress reducing
techniques like
meditation yoga massages
and watching my videos however
it's important to remember that cortisol
and adrenaline
are not bad these are crucial chemicals
in living
a healthy happy life it's cortisol like
gets you out of bed in the morning gets
adrenaline that
gives you the kick to act in important
situations
but the key here is balance balance with
what you may ask well that leads me on
to
our next chemical dehydrophyll
dehydrophysium dehydr
dhea apart from being impossible to
pronounce
the hormone known as dhea is a natural
high performance chemical in fact it's
so potent
that the synthetic version has been
banned in most professional sports
this chemical gives us our vitality and
it is
associated with a healthy high
functioning body and mind
it is a counterpoint to cortisol the
more cortisol we have the
less dhea and vice versa
dhea is directly linked to aging which
is the main reason it has received so
much attention from scientists
endocrinologists
and other people who value their
youthful looks dhea production starts in
the womb
fetal adrenal glands produce about 200
milligrams of dhea a day
10 times that's produced when you're an
adult after you're born this production
drops to almost nothing and it stays
that way until you reach puberty
this is probably because dhea acts as a
precursor to producing hormones like
estrogen progesterone and testosterone a
study of traders and testosterone found
your long-term business prospects
might also have something to do with
your fingers
in men and boys the right pointer finger
is shorter in relation to the right ring
finger
than it is in girls the higher your
testosterone level before birth the
lower your pointer finger to ring finger
ratio according to a study of
testosterone and traders
men with the lowest pointer to ring
finger ratios
made the most money and had the most
long-term success
but as the swedish king crew ate himself
to death
adolf frederick learnt you can have too
much of a good thing
both cortisol and dhea are essential for
life
and as we've discussed too much cortisol
and too little dhea
can have serious health implications
including the debilitating condition
cushing's syndrome but too little
cortisol
causes the life-threatening addison's
disease
you need to maintain a happy balance
and on the subject of happy let's
introduce the next two chemicals in our
hit parade
dopamine and serotonin like cortisol and
adrenaline dopamine and serotonin
love to work together serotonin is the
happiness chemical and is fundamental to
our sense of well-being
it's produced when we laugh or eat
chocolate and the persistent deficiency
of this chemical can lead to depression
if you ever find it difficult to be
happy when you're stressed that's partly
because serotonin levels
are negatively impacted by high cortisol
what's the remedy fake it till you make
it
just smile crazy as it sounds
studies suggest that happiness doesn't
just cause smiling
smiling causes happiness by stimulating
the release of serotonin and other
neurotransmitters like dopamine and
oxytocin which we'll cover later
smiling even when you don't feel like it
can trick your brain
into believing you're happy the effects
go even further happiness has a positive
influence on the immune system
one study suggested that smiling can
even shorten our recovery time from
stress
and reduce one's heart rate and another
study performed at the university of
cardiff in wales
found that people who could not frown
due to botox injections
were happier on average than those who
could frown
whoever thought injecting your face with
a lethal toxin
could be the secret to happiness
serotonin
is core to feeling happy but
so is dopamine dopamine
is the feel good hormone it's released
as a reward for purely hedonistic
pleasures
such as sex eating chocolate
binge watching netflix or all three at
once
if you're feeling particularly talented
it also kicks in when we experience
success like
scoring the winning goal in a sports
game or getting a sought after promotion
at work
buddha postulated that life is suffering
and if the teachings of the man with
boobs is to be believed
then it is natural to further
extrapolate that almost all human
behavior can be reduced
to either the avoidance of pain or the
pursuit
of pleasure to soothe one's existential
suffering
and that makes dopamine possibly the
most important brain chemical of all
it affects one's attention span focus
motivation
willpower and what one considers to be
important in his life
to illustrate this let's use science's
go-to proxy for humans
rats when influenced by dopamine rats
will pull a lever
over and over again to get food
we can all relate to this anytime you
eat or drink too much of something be it
cake or beer that's because dopamine has
caused a reward sentence in your brain
to regard something as
valuable even necessary
even though you don't need any more of
it and you really should have stopped
after the third slice of cheesecake
barbara
when taken to its extremes dopamine
causes addiction
a person with low levels of dopamine is
more likely to get addicted to drugs
alcohol food or whatever it is that
provides his pleasure fix
the fast food industry knows this better
than anyone
it has spent years of research and
millions of dollars to achieve
just the right balance of salt sugar and
fat
to make that pizza burger or glazed
doughnut in your hand
literally irresistible the dopamine
mechanism also explains why people will
do
irrational even depraved and violent
things to get more
of an addictive substance let's turn to
our rodent friends again
in lab studies rats with more dopamine
have proved willing to climb a wall
to get to a larger pile of food than the
pile
right in front of them in short
dopamine's motivational pull
is so strong that it reshapes one's
perception
of effort even risk
dopamine depletion can lead to moodiness
forgetfulness
apathy and poor concentration basically
you turn back into a teenager when
experiencing these symptoms it's common
to reach for a boost through
caffeine nicotine or high sugar high fat
foods these are all very effective in
delivering a dopamine shot
but dopamine only provides an empty and
shallow form of pleasure the long-term
impact of creating this reward circuit
in your brain
is seldom positive if your dopamine is
low
get some exercise and work at reducing
your stress through relaxation
find yourself a hobby and a purpose
instead of filling your time with
hedonistic pursuits and instead of fast
food you're better off eating foods high
in
tyrosine an amino acid that helps your
brain to create more dopamine via
a less artificial process like cheese
fish meat dairy soy
seeds nuts beans and lentils
red and yellow bananas are full of
dopamine and very useful if you have a
snail infestation too
being a diuretic dopamine is deadly to
all slimy creatures like snails
slugs and that dodgy uncle nobody wants
to invite to christmas
so next time piedo pete does come
knocking for his jolly holidays
try lobbing bananas at him to finish off
our trip down brain chemical lane
we've saved my favorite for last
oxytocin
this is known by many names the love
hormone the cuddle chemical
the hug hormone even the moral molecule
if brain chemicals were the beetles
oxytocin
would be john lennon imagine all the
people
living life in peace that's oxytocin
talking
and the class a drugs this hormone is
deeply interwoven with our sense of
connection
and belonging when you feel like the
people around you are there for you
oxytocin levels increase however if you
feel excluded
or unseen oxytocin drops
your body and mind are flooded with
oxytocin when you fall in love
it's the fuel for the honeymoon period
of any relationship
it's nature's way of making us blind to
the many
idiosyncrasies and annoying as
habits that begin to drive us crazy
when we've been with someone for more
than a few months
without oxytocin we may never hang
around long enough to build the bonds
that lead to procreation
and the survival of the species itself
bond building may also be why
breastfeeding stimulates the release of
oxytocin
this has been labelled the tend and
befriend response
in contrast of the fight or flight
response mentioned earlier it's a
helpful comparison because unlike the
survival stress triggered by cortisol
and adrenaline
oxytocin stimulates relaxation lowers
anxiety
and decreases blood pressure research
suggests that oxytocin may encourage men
to stay faithful to their partners
which confirms an opinion long held by
many women
men are voles well
one particular vote to be precise
the prairie role common to europe and
asia is naturally
monogamous part of the only three
percent of the mammal kingdom
that takes one mate for life
science has yet to prove whether humans
also fall within this category
once prairie voles mate they stay
together
for good by contrast the prairie vole's
cousin
the montaigne vol couldn't be less
interested in commitment
despite the two species sharing 99
percent of the same
genes life for the montaigne vole is a
series of one-night stands
and raging rodent orgies scientists
believe that the difference involved
behavior
may come down to oxytocin reception
oxytocin is released in the prairie
vole's brain during mating
when the hormone is blocked the vol
tends to treat sex
as a once-off affair similar to his
montane
kinfolk however when the hormone is
added to the prairie vole's brain
without the vole having sex
he still develops a bond with his
partner
what happens when we add oxytocin to the
mantein vole
nothing he carries on philandering as
usual
the difference it seems is not the
chemical itself
but whether the animal's brain is
designed to receive it
so the big question is are human brains
identical to those
of cute little woodland rodents
obviously not
but the lesson is the same our behavior
can be radically shifted
by changing the mix of hormones and
neurotransmitters in the brain
everything from the food we crave to the
people we desire
can be altered by the levels of
different brain chemicals flowing
through our gray matter
but you're no victim of this process you
are the master of what happens in your
brain
so look after it treat it right
and you will strike the right chemical
notes for a life
well lived thank you for watching
you can now pre-order my brand's new
book stick a flag in it
on amazon link in the description thank
you